it sounds conspiratorial but the first
thing you have to know to to understand
is
build back better
when i first heard that i didn't realize
what it was and it was joe biden's
slogan
to be elected and i thought
who came up with buildback better that
is the worst slogan i've ever heard
and it it's because it was not that's
not its original language now they're
using buildback better in uh for the
prime minister of the uk prime minister
of japan they're using it in france
they're using it in canada it is the
slogan of the great reset
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the host of the glenn beck program and
the author of the great reset joe biden
and the rise of 21st century fascism
glenn beck welcome back to the reuben
report thank you very much dave how are
you
i'm just fine my friend you have
recouped from kovid people were you know
celebrating your demise
i know i was on the levin show and he
said how you feeling and i said other
than having covid in my
you know and uh and the country being
destroyed i'm good
and he was like wait do you have covid
and i'm like yeah no big deal uh it's
going into my lungs now which it always
does and i wasn't free i kept saying i'm
not freaked out i'm not freaked out it's
no big deal it's no big deal oh my gosh
the world was like set on fire glenn
beck has coveted he should die
it was bizarre glenn why is it maybe you
can explain this to me you know a bit
about my political evolution why is it
that every time one of my friends get
coveted you dennis prager people want
them to die why is that you guys are
good people as far as i'm concerned am i
missing something glenn
i think because
the um and it's happening to the right
too
we are being dehumanized so we're not
real people and
and because of our point of view they're
already talking about you know
uh no medical care we shouldn't be in
society i mean it's it's it's exactly
what happened
in the 1930s in other places um
it just happens to be that it's the
political point of view now that's not
acceptable and what's scary is 57
of democrats say
it's 48 i think that say you shouldn't
have your children if you won't get them
vaccinated and 57 say maybe we should
put you in a camp
that's terrifying terrifying
so that that kind of is what the book is
about to some extent because it's it's
about that there has been a move on all
of us in our freedoms for quite some
time i want to show the cover again here
and we'll put up a proper image as well
because it's a scary cover these faces
these are these are three scary which
one of these people it's soros for me
for sure out of klaus schwab soros and
and biden
when you see immediately seems like the
scariest one like you wouldn't want to
see him in a dark alley yeah no i think
he i mean he looks and more and more
every day like the emperor first yeah he
looks like palpatine yeah um so i think
the scariest to me is soros he has
believe it or not um kind of the least
to do with the actual
uh verbiage in the book but he is the
guy who started the wef with klaus
schwab
klaush is the guy who is really pushing
it but without soros there wouldn't be a
place to push it and without soros it
wouldn't be being pushed he is a huge
force
the other one is joe biden who
uh has bought into this 100
and is on the road uh to
to transform
not just america but the entire western
world in ways that will affect your life
that you can't even imagine yet when you
get to the end of the book you'll
realize
everything is about to change how i eat
how i dress
what i say
how i pick my job do i get to pick my
job my kids in school
they're going to be fast-tracked will
they get to pick their own career
everything is changing so when you say
this you obviously are talking about the
great reset which was a phrase that if
we were to utter
say a year ago people would say you were
conspiracy theorists but as everyone
knows yesterday's conspiracy theorist is
now today's truth teller you've been
warning about sort of all of this stuff
forever i think the first time that we
sat down which is probably about five
years ago now i said i used to watch you
on fox you'd have the board behind you
and i'd go and you'd be scribbling all
this stuff and running across the room
and the whole thing and i'd be going
this guy is half genius half crazy half
entertainer and i know that that's three
halves but there was just a lot there
but you have you really have been sort
of tracking all of this from the
financial system to the political system
and everything else so i guess where did
you like in retrospect i suppose looking
back now do you see a moment when you
first started putting the pieces
together for some of this stuff uh yeah
so i started first starting putting the
pieces together and i didn't know what i
was dealing with up until about a year
and a half ago i mean i thought we were
dealing with socialists and
we're not the socialists are being used
anybody who's a marxist boy are you
gonna be pissed
when they finally show up yeah um it is
that is cover to hide what's really
going on and i didn't figure that one
out but i do remember
um sitting in my studio in radio city
and i was getting ready to do a show
and there was a a little article i mean
it was literally i mean just a few
paragraphs uh in the wall street journal
buried and it was about a
uh
one of the congressmen
uh introducing and then them passing
this bill that you could not take your
money out of the united states with you
and i thought
hmm somebody knows something is coming
somebody knows i mean we've never had a
problem with exodus of money what is
that
and that's when i first started going
wait a minute what's going on and then
i realized
that
when they say they want to make the
world fair and equitable
it was about 2007 or eight that i
realized well you can't do that you
can't bring the rest of the world up to
the united states because we've tried
and it's getting better
but it's not up it's not up to parity so
the easy thing to do is bring the united
states down to everybody else's level
and that's what we're doing
so let's talk about the joe biden part
of this because i want to talk about
sort of the the machine behind it but
let's just get to like the parts that i
think are a little more easy for people
to understand first on the joe biden
part do you think biden is fully aware
of what he is part of like the the sort
of year you think he is that in this
last year the level of destruction that
has been brought across this country
supply chain inflation the whole shebang
afghanistan everything
i'm not sure he's aware i'm not sure he
understands
the impact but he does he is fully aware
and and and committed to the direction
i don't know how much he sees of the
wreckage uh but he is committed to the
direction and and i say that because his
first speech in front of congress
remember he got in it was about a month
later and it was kind of a state of the
union thing
and if you knew what you were looking
for
it was terrifying terrifying
he started when he came in and remember
they were all sitting like six feet
apart and so not everybody was there and
he said you are the ones and i remember
thinking he's at first he's looking at
the camera and talking to us and he's
like you are the ones and then he
started pointing and looking at all the
people in congress that have saved the
world and you are the ones here that
made things happen he wasn't talking to
the american people he was talking to
the elites in that room
the next thing he said and he said it
twice
plus he briefed the news anchors
prior to the speech on what he was going
to talk about in the real problem in
america and he said it twice in the
speech he said you know
we have to decide whether our system of
government can um
compete
with these new authoritarian governments
like china
and the jury's still out
well
he said before the speech
that um he still bet non-america but and
i don't know if it's going to survive it
has to dramatically change so they are
what they put together literally is the
definition of fascism
forget about the jack boots forget about
what you think that means
look at the real definition that is a
public-private partnership with private
businesses and if you're in the party or
you're doing what the party wants you to
do you're fine the minute you're not
you're out whether that is you know a a
slave camp or you're just out kicking
rocks that's what's happening in china
and china is the model here
do you think that basically the last 20
years of us diplomacy with china we
thought that we could get them a little
to be a little more like us
and in fact it actually just worked out
the other way that we just didn't have
the wherewithal to stand for
american values and and fight for the
good stuff that we've been doing here
for 200 plus years i think that changed
maybe around clinton and i include the
republicans in this thinking as well
um i think
in the 90s at some point
they
the business people and the government
saw
okay this is communism light
uh this isn't the jack-booted thugs even
though it was
uh and they can move quickly and they
can do things quickly and they can just
direct
um you know policies and hey we're going
to be number one in cars so let's focus
on cars
uh and and they loved that and i
remember in the 90s hearing from very
big business people you know china is
just a different place and it's very
exciting and it is quote it is the new
model
and i remember back in the 90s going
well i don't want china to be our model
that's not what we are
and the big business and government just
started working hand in hand over the
last 20 years
and moving towards that and saying it's
much better because we can get things
done
so the argument basically that you're
laying out the book is that through the
world economic forum klaus schwab
then some of these ngos and all the
stuff that soros is finding and then
with the president of the united states
that are all sort of together
working to to bring this here i mean so
is it is it here i mean is it fully here
it is here we're just in it now we're in
we are living the very beginnings of it
it is here it's not too late to change
it but dave what's so frustrating about
the sales of the book it the sa the book
sold out on day one
uh the next printing i can get uh is i
think they come out at the end of
february
those i believe are all sold out we're
on our third printing which will come
out in march people have to read this
now time is of the essence it is so
frustrating um
we are in it and it is it sounds
conspiratorial but the first thing you
have to know to to understand is
build back better
when i first heard that i didn't realize
what it was and it was joe biden's
slogan
to be elected and i thought
who came up with buildback better that
is the worst slogan i've ever heard
and it it's because it was not that's
not its original language now they're
using buildback better
in uh for the prime minister of the uk
prime minister of japan they're using it
in france they're using it in canada
it is the slogan of the great reset when
we went into kovid if you remember right
and i was looking for it so maybe you
won't remember
they all said
a new normal we're gonna go back to a
new normal well i knew what they were
talking about because before they said
new normal several said the great reset
and
that's what they have been uh sharing
and moving us towards is this great
reset so a it's not a conspiracy and
it's almost when you read the book it is
almost the rosetta stone
for the news you will understand
why was home depot allowed to stay open
but my local hardware store couldn't
why is it
i can go to a restaurant
especially a chain restaurant i can sit
down and as soon as i sit down i can
take off my mask but when i go to an air
on an airplane i'm seated but i have to
use the mask in between and that air
filtering system is far superior than
any restaurant i've ever been in glen
i thought it was because of science yes
yeah no it's not about science it's all
about my notes definitely confused here
so okay so it is about control we're in
the beginnings of it do you see any
markers
that show us the way out of this so for
example as we're taping this right now
there is a massive probably the biggest
world worldwide convoy of trucks
happening in canada right now in protest
of these mandates of these lockdowns
which is directly connected obviously to
everything else you're talking about
here that's pretty good right that's
pretty good that's great and it is those
things that will stop it but what has to
be stopped the most important thing that
cannot get its roots any deeper
if you're an investor a 401k and let's
say you have your 401k through you know
uh
uh i don't know jp morgan or whatever
i want you to go to your website and see
look for esg scores
and i think it's charles schwab that has
the esg score for your account
and when i've talked about this
um i think it was bank of america or
city one of the banks called and said no
no that's not what esgs are about we're
never going to use them for people and i
said then why is your subsidiary using
it on my account why do i have an esg
score and they said well that's because
we're doing that because a lot of people
really care about social justice and
environment and governance of the boards
and so we're just helping them know who
they're investing in and i said you're
so full of crap you can't see through
the brown in your eyes for the love of
pete um now they are clear on this esg
has to be stopped right now because that
is the control
of your business of your money of
absolutely everything in your life it is
your social credit score and it is
starting at the bank level for
businesses all of the big businesses
they're all in on esg
uh warning that is the fascistic system
that will trickle down to you
and glenn call me crazy but do you think
they might be able to link something
like an esg score to perhaps a vaccine
passport would is that something a crazy
person might that's why the passport on
the vaccine passport is so important you
know i was talking to one of those
truckers that was in canada and he had
to deliver something to the united
states he has to have the app on his
phone that he shows
uh and you know you just scan the qr he
got to the border for the canadian
crossing he went to to the united states
and then turned around after he dropped
his load and he was coming uh back into
canada he had his phone on the qr code
and he was ready to put it out the
window and and to show it to the guy he
rolls the window down he starts moving
towards and the guy goes no i got that
uh you're okay go ahead and he said wait
a minute aren't you supposed to scan
this and he said no
um and i don't remember the distance but
it was like you know when you're within
a quarter of a mile all of that is
transmitted to us we know exactly who
you are
holy cow and by the way
if you think this is nuts it has gotten
so bad in china that you cannot leave
your house without your phone
if you do
the facial recognition finds you they
send the police out to you to say go
back to your house and get your phone
it is such a part of life now you you've
heard the amber alert
that's what happens when you start to
approach someone who has a low credit
score
if you have a low social credit score
everybody's phone around that person
warns them don't get any closer or it'll
affect your score this stuff with joe
rogan
is not about covid it's not it's about
silencing any kind of descent and if
they win with rogan we're gone we're
gone so we covered that on my show this
morning i i said it is the biggest
cultural and political story of the day
it is and i mean by the way i don't mean
literally today i mean right now it is
the biggest thing because it's a marker
for everything do you think rogan's
going to be able to stand up to this
thing because you know he gave a pretty
good uh pushback but they are spotify
now is putting disclaimers in front of
his videos which he said he welcomed uh
so do you think do you think he can
fight here's the thing i i don't know
i mean i think you know logan i don't i
don't know joe um but he seems like a
guy who really knows who he is
um and
uh the problem he has and you know this
dave we've talked about this
if you don't have your own platform
and even with your own platform
amazon can
cut you off
um the banks can cut you off
if you don't have your own platform
where are you going to go
he just traded youtube which would have
kicked him off by now traded youtube and
all those views and easy access without
a paywall he traded that to go over to
spotify
he was smart enough to make sure that
they're paying him money doesn't talk it
screams
a hundred million dollars
screams to him but it also screams to
spotify you don't flush that down the
toilet
it can he make some adjustments to his
show
yeah he shouldn't we should all be
outraged that the federal government the
only reason why spotify did anything
they don't care about joni mitchell for
the love of nobody
joni mitchell's family doesn't care
about joni mitchell
so
it's it's not that it's that the surgeon
general came out
and on advice from the white house
and said this is dangerous to people and
you know social media and spotify they
need to step up their game well that is
the very clear definition of a violation
of the first amendment there's the
government
using their power to coerce somebody to
do something
i i don't know dave if he survives i
hope he does
but this is
kovid is only the pregame
financial
is the real game and when our economy
starts to collapse
the great reset people back in december
did a uh a nine or ten day
war game on a financial collapse and the
first thing that they did was they had
to silence the people who were saying
anything other than the official truth
and what they were saying was these
people are going to get the entire
financial system globally to collapse
you've got to shut them up and those
people were saying i don't think i
believe the bank on this this or this or
maybe you should get your money out of
the bank because bank holidays are
coming all of those things are true
as they wargamed but they will silence
us quickly
the move that the uh surgeon general
made that comment that he made that you
know that the big tech companies they
should look into this sort of thing is
very consistent with what this
administration did i'm sure you saw the
video i'm sure you covered it when jen
saki a couple months back yeah we flag
things for facebook we
i mean have they just have they just
figured out a way around the first
amendment at this point i mean the first
amendment is
what they just did is against the the
first amendment well it's not a law in
other words have they just figured out
the wink and it works that you don't
need to pass a law yeah so that is the
thing about the great reset
everyone is a
stakeholder and it is a complete end run
around the constitution around all
governments it is an amazing thing
by the way he's still pushing his build
back better uh uh package guess who else
is doing that right now
uh england has a build back better
package almost the same i think france
does as well germany has one as well and
they're all exactly the same
it's just how open and honest are you
going to be on what it's going to cost
we're saying that it's free
i think germany is saying yeah we're
going to tax the snot out of you
so does the u.s because of the way we're
set up different states and as you know
i was pretty damn close to moving to
texas we talked about it at your house i
mean i was pretty damn close candace
tried to sell me on nashville but all
right i settled here in florida and i
got to tell you man it's freaking
fantastic i know do you think that our
that our federalist system is at least
set up to fight this thing better where
in places like britain and france that
you mentioned they don't have that vocal
control yes so we are we are in the best
position remember this is not an
american thing this is all of the
western world um and we are in the best
position unfortunately we're taking the
lead on a lot of it
and that's why every step you take
towards silencing voices or giving the
government more power the worse this
becomes because there will be a another
emergency that they will use to finally
grab that uh rope and pull it taut
around our necks but our federalist
system works it's really heartening to
see two states
one state i think was was it nebraska
that passed their uh article five
constitutional convention yeah and then
there was another state that was doing
it this weekend as well
it has to happen our states have to
separate themselves from the federal
government on certain issues you cannot
come in and tell us what to do the local
and state is the only thing that will
stop this there are three states i
talked to them
i don't know a week after the book came
out and uh i think it was the the the
treasury secretary of west virginia
it is also texas and
uh new hampshire that are putting laws
in right now because of the great reset
to ban all banks from using esg scores
because that
they're saying that that's the way
they're going to make all their
financial decisions well no that has
nothing to do with credit scores that
has everything to do with politics and
they're banning them if we could get
half the states to ban esgs with
financial institutions
you'd be
a long way down that federalist road
that would stop this so what can we do
individually besides the people that
should probably pick up and go if you
live in california and you live in new
york the places that are going to be the
epicenters for this nonsense i mean what
can people do like would you recommend
people actually take their money out of
chase and put it in the local federal
credit union in their city i mean is
that that's probably a small step 100
that's a big step
because if all of our audiences did that
it would shake the financial markets
they would be like wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute
how much money have you lost
because that's the money that they are
using and by the way
after september i'm sorry after uh
08 and the banking collapse
the laws were changed the money you have
in your checking and savings
you are the depositor of last resort so
you can't go get your money if they say
you know there's a banking crisis we
need all the money we can get you have
zero access to the money
you're the last uh
debtor that they need to pay you're not
the first
so
i'm not giving my money to these big
financial institutions you go to your
local credit union make sure that
everything is i can't remember the
acronym for the fdic for uh right
there's a separate one yeah a separate
one but you make sure that it's insured
and you put everything there it's so
critical
that we are not taking money our money
loaning money giving money to these
banks that are then spreading it all
over america and the news that broke
last week all over the world
instead we must
keep it local we have to strengthen our
local communities our local businesses
so best way to do it and i would do it
today take your money and tell them why
i'm not going to be in a a bank that is
involved and has esg scores i'm going to
a local credit union do it today
so speaking of things that you can do
today we're all watching you know the
supply chain stuff and it took me i
moved to florida a month ago it took the
truck literally five weeks to get here
because the truck with all my stuff just
came this week because they can only get
trucks to drive one way because in a
normal time trucks are going both ways
with stuff they can and they also can't
get drivers anymore and the price of gas
went up and the supply chain you can't
get stuff to build out and say a house
or a studio and everything else do we
just need to build a parallel economy at
every level and i mean from banks to to
a new home depot to just the whole damn
thing we're gonna have to buy our own
candy shops and you you start by um
putting your money into a local bank and
just realize it's the george bailey
savings and loan
you know it has to stay local they are
mr potter that is the best movie to
explain the great reset you know he
looks at people just as you know they're
bums and they're never gonna get
anywhere so he'll take their money and
he'll build potterville and that is what
they're building in the western world is
potterville
can i ask you one question dave sure
what are you doing with bitcoin i put my
money in bitcoin and i'm like let it
ride
but now with the treasury
the the fed the imf
they are going to kill these things
what are you doing are you leaving it in
or are you taking it out yeah so i have
a chunk of bitcoin not not not a ton but
i have several bitcoin and i'm just
leaving it i've never touched any of it
and i just wanted to sit there and see
what happens i actually was going to ask
you in a few minutes about you know
biden now wants to regulate bitcoin
which is the whole purpose of a
decentralized
coin a whole decentralized system is to
not be regulated and you can see
obviously anyone watching this can
understand why that would be separate
that's the off ramp for this insanity i
think people have to have it you have to
be able to diversify because if they
come for you if what you're laying out
here is right and by and large i think
it is it's like you're going to need
some other ways to to have commerce with
people you're going to be able when the
[ __ ] hits the fan i mean you're going to
need to be able to trade goods and
services with people and that that's
where crypto comes in so that's where i
go to
um you know i i live
here in the city in dallas
but if crap starts to hit the fan i've
got another house in a very small
farming community and that's where i'm
planning on on being with my family and
friends is in this really small
tight-knit community
and we're right now working on you know
the farmer's market
we are talking to each other hey what do
you have in your tool shed
that can make things you know what do
you have and so we're not
buying the same things
um that we can share if things really
get bad that we can fix everything that
we need that's the kind of stuff that um
i think we really need to look at
be are you in a community of like-minded
people
that will help each other because dave
there's something else that i touch on
in the book
this what's so insidious about this is
i have been talking since probably 1995
there is a new
industrial revolution that is coming
that will be as profound as the
industrial revolution but it when it
starts it will happen in a 10-year
period not a hundred years
well we're there we are already i think
i think we're year two in that industry
of the fourth industrial revolution and
by 2030 40 of jobs are going to be gone
maybe there'll be some new things but
probably not
that's why we're talking about you know
basic universal income and everything
else because tech knows what is coming
and now so do our politicians
um the one thing that we are that
everybody is pushing us the opposite
direction that we have to recognize stop
and go the other way
is empathy
the only thing that a.i cannot duplicate
is empathy if you're looking to tell
your kids what kind of job are you going
to get
you you'd be really wise to say forget
about school or whatever if you if you
want to be a nurse go to school not a
doctor a nurse
go to school and make sure you focus
everything on empathy because
the ai is going to tell you everything
that's going on in that person
you have to be the one that is the face
that comes in and says it's all right
everything is all right it's going to be
okay
because ai cannot do that
um that's where its whole is
also if a if the world is run by a.i or
people that you know just think of other
people as sheep
um
gosh they are missing all empathy
and that's a pretty dark world
you know it's interesting i actually
heard you talking about this this
empathy with ai and the robots and that
even when they show the when you see the
robots that we have now they cannot show
true human emotion they do these things
that actually look completely
counter to human emotion when they try
to show human emotions it looks it looks
more robotic than you would think
robotic would even look um so hang on in
animation that's called the what is it
the erie valley or the creepy uh the
uncanny valley the uncanny valley
and animation has found a way
where they're coming out of the uncanny
valley they don't think ai will ever get
out of the uncanny valley because it is
something
really truly spiritual
human in the eyes
and when you see it you know it and
there's a lot of people that you can
talk to that just don't have that you
know they might feel sorry for you but
they're not those people that have real
empathy and you know the difference and
ai will never be able to compete with
that is that the weird moment that we're
in that everything you're describing
here
sounds like a dystopian movie most
likely or a book that was originally
written by philip k dick but i mean
everything you sound it's this sort of
sounds like minority report it sort of
sounds like terminator it sort of sounds
like i robot like we're rushing to a
matrix for sure that we're rushing
towards it we all have had all the
warnings the warning signs are all
behind us they were in books they were
in movies they're in history they're in
the bible they're all there and we're
just rushing and we're all going
oh you know let's keep going because
who's gonna stop us
right and we all kind of know too yeah
we all know something i don't care what
political stripe you are you're all we
all know something is really not right
something this is not going to end well
we know it uh and you know what's what's
crazy is
uh
in many ways
the liberals were right
we were wrong we thought it would come
as you know some
communist marxist thing those guys are
being used this is coming through our
corporations
every time i watch a dystopian movie i
roll my eyes when they're like oh i work
for the corporation aka the government
i'm like ah stop it
that is what they're right and how the
left
is i'm against big pharmaceutical
companies
really except for right now when it
comes
i mean it's crazy they knew all this
stuff we mocked them and now we're
standing where they were going guys
uh you were right i mean
can't you see this
but you got to kind of admire it right
like not what it's doing but the trick
that it pulled right there you got to
admire it that these people you've got
as you're saying they're the pawns these
communists and socialists and all these
people they're the pawns and the foot
soldiers and they think that they're
against the power while they literally
are for all the corporations they're for
all of the messaging i walk into target
yesterday to buy some cleaning supplies
and there is a massive black lives
matter section there and it's like
you're fighting the power really with
that shirt and sweatshirt and pants and
shoes i think in a hundred years dave
this is going to be studied in every
government uh program
uh that is you know
trying to teach about the history and
government and behavioral science
this is
this is the time that the world will
look back
i think we're going to be studied for a
thousand years
especially
if we defeat it
no nation has ever defeated anything
like this
i think we could be
the exception to that rule but only if
we all wake up don't go down the road of
conspiracies just get the actual facts
because they're worse than any anybody
that could come up with conspiracies
online
these are true
and if you just do that remain calm work
on empathy don't play into their hands
we beat them and here's why i know this
have you ever seen the government
ever work this hard
to silence people and keep them in line
i've never seen it
if they thought we were sheep if they
thought we couldn't stop it they
wouldn't care they wouldn't do any of
this but they are working over overtime
and they're talking now of probably
about at least 50 percent of the country
remember to change things it only it's
the tipping point is like 19 or 20
percent
they're talking about half of the nation
that's pretty significant and they know
it
have you in all the time you've been
talking about this and taken you know
dozens of callers every day on your
radio show and everything else have you
learned anything about the type of
person the makeup of the person or the
belief system of the person that is
willing to go into the fire and be the
guy in their social circle that's going
to talk about this stuff and change
people and everything else because i get
some version of this question a lot
people want they kind of get it but you
know they've got their job they kind of
get it but they've got their family they
they don't want to really get in but now
i think you're right we are getting to
this odd critical mass i mean when you
know and you've pushed canadians to do
what they're doing up there you know
something's wrong
they never they're never pissed off
about anything anything ever so what do
you what do you think is it what do you
think it is that that
we can do to help ignite that thing in
people not just know about this stuff
but that other thing the other thing so
i think the the easiest line to cross i
mean nancy pelosi chloe's saying it's
for the children it's for the children
so it's not about the children with them
it is about the children with individual
families and moms and dads that's why
you saw the pushback coming at school
that's why you saw i mean i have friends
who are very liberal thought who could
never have voted for anybody but joe
biden
that are really smoked right now and the
tipping point was you wait you want to
vaccinate my little my little ones are
you kidding me
never
it is our children that speak to us that
make us much more
brave
um
but i think it's just connecting we have
to connect enough people
the week i released the book all i kept
hearing in my head was the eyes of the
world are upon you
that's what fdi sorry that's what dwight
eisenhower said on the day of d-day to
the troops
the eyes of the world are upon you
and what you do today
will decide the freedom of men and women
all over the world
we need to get
to a place to where people understand
this is our world war ii
this is our opportunity is it going to
be lost in this generation
and if they really truly understand that
then they'll
be
courageous because people with children
don't want my kids i have them in 30s
and i have them as teenagers
and the older ones have come to me and
went so dad
what is life going to be like now for my
kids
and my answer is it's yet to be decided
if we do all that we're supposed to do
it will be fine we're going to go
through really difficult times but we
make it out on the other end
if we don't if we don't stand up
dave this is all of the technology
that hitler wanted i mean it's it's
you know the um what's his name javal uh
noah
ferrari yeah you know him yeah so
in his book he talks about
that
the age of
free will
is over
and he says that's right now that you
don't really make the decisions that you
think you make because you're so
influenced by what you see and it starts
with oh you're finished with that book
you'd like this one
and so we're losing our decision-making
free will ability we have to exercise
that we have to exercise courage in the
smallest ways because if you're not
if you're not building courage now it is
only going to get harder and you won't
be able to deadlift that weight
you know i don't know that i've ever
connected this directly before but you
know i do my off the grid august thing
which you've welcomed me back on before
but i do always feel more brave after
every the five year the five years that
i've done it i feel i always expect it
to feel clear-minded but i always feel
that i have this renewed sense of
passion to get right back in and keep
fighting for the things that i believe
because the algorithms haven't been
telling you every day all day
you're too small you're too small you're
too small
you think there's something there there
might there might be something there
i think so
so in our last couple in our last couple
of minutes um
not to connect this back to politics
purely because i think we're talking
about something that's bigger than
politics but you and i did not vote for
trump the first time around we both did
the second time around
if he had been president now if he had
won that last election was that the
was that the wall that we needed no pun
intended with trump i mean was that the
thing and then he was the thing that was
gonna at least temporarily stop it or
the dam or something like that
so i truly believe i have no evidence to
back this up other than all of the
corporations banded together to stop him
which was unusual
i am
convinced that this is the real reason
why they stopped him it wasn't about
anything else except
he's america first
so we can't get him on this bandwagon
the minute he canceled the paris accords
which was not about global warming it is
about esg and the financial system
that's all it's about is the banking
system
when he canceled that
they realized we're
done
if he doesn't if he stays in and they
they had to destroy him
i don't know because he i think he kicks
down walls he's got a good gut on him
and he kicks down walls not necessarily
knowing what's behind it but that's not
good over there my gut tells me these
people over here are doing no good
um
if uh if he knows
and he's willing to stand up against it
which i think he would be
uh he would be very very
uh very good i'm not sure he fully
understands
what he exposed
yet
even after your recent sit down with him
do you think
he didn't get it not that you fully went
into all of this but
i said to him uh and i've asked him
because i just talked to him again on
friday and i asked him the same question
mr president
you have to clear
out
every agency you've got to fire
all of them
and he said i know
one thing he said was i
um
i can't do it with the gop that i have
because it will take an act of congress
and senator and senate he can't do it
with mitch mcconnell they just won't do
it um he needs
he needs help in congress and in the
senate to be able to clean out
the viper's nest i had a i had a
congressman who's very low key makes
makes mike lee look a little hyper at
times uh
who said to me on friday glenn
um the fbi is the kgb and i'm like i'm
sorry excuse me
and he said it is the kgb and we all in
washington know it and no one's doing
anything about it uh and they have to be
cleaned out
trump i asked
this friday
are you
working with a council of people are you
doing anything
to draw up a naughty and nice list
and figure out what you're going to do
because you only have four years if you
run and win four years that's not enough
and this is going to be this will be a
death match
uh to do this i think he's the only guy
who would
but i don't know
if he will
or understands it yet
glenn i have only one more question for
you which is fairly obvious after this
conversation
can i come to this special unknown place
and have a small parcel of land
listen you know i had chickens i know
how to i know how to deal with the coupe
i know how to clean i've gotten pretty
good at a couple other handy things in a
new house here and i you know and i'm
pretty decent for conversations as long
as you just make sure you always say i'm
from florida
you can come i'm going to literally have
to erase the first thirty-five oh yeah
i've never lived in california what are
you talking about
another dave rubin looks just like me
glenn it's always an honor talking to
you and i'm glad to be in the fight with
you and uh hope to see you in the free
state of texas or in the free state of
florida i think i'm coming to florida in
a couple of weeks so i'll have to see
you then
we'll fire up the grill see you soon god
bless if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell